buried in groups from the boat they were
found on in the mediterranean sea
some of the dozens of migrants and
asylum seekers located in the early
hours of this morning
they were taken aboard the louise
michelle a rescue vessel which found
itself in trouble
after a series of operations in recent
days more than 200 people were left
crammed onto the ship
or in a lifeboat nearby the vessel was
effectively stranded
unable to move because of the sheer
weight of numbers
its crews say european nations ignored
calls for help
for hours uh it has been for a long time
it has
been italy has been most responsive due
to
its geographical position
where malta a long time already refused
any kind of
assistance of course
all european member states are in the
responsibility to take care of what's
happening
at european orders the luis michelle is
funded by the british street artist
banksy
and features some of his familiar art he
put out a strong video condemning the
lack of response
his message adding to mounting criticism
of the european union's
migration policy this is their
responsibility
and people should not be dying at sea
people should be rescued
immediately and disembark in a safe boat
as soon as possible
the louise michelle was converted into a
rescue vessel to help migrants and
asylum seekers trying to reach europe
from africa via libya and the
mediterranean sea
dozens have lost their lives trying to
make that dangerous journey in recent
weeks
and the fate of those on board the
vessel will present extra challenges
for european governments michelle
clifford sky news